اذا الحرب في اوكرانيا تقترب من طي صفحه
شهرها التاسع والحل يبدو بعيد المنال مع
تمسك بعدم التفاوض مع موسكو الا بانسحابها
الرئيس الاوكراني فولودي ميرسيدينسكي سبعه
فكره اقرار هدنه قصيره مع روسيا وقال انها
لن تؤدي الا الى التفاؤكم الامور اعتبر ان
اي هدنه في الوقت الحالي ستمنح روسيا فتره
راحه لاستعاده قوتها وان السلامه الحقيقيه
والدائم لا يمكن تحقيقه الا عبر التدمير
الكامل للقوات الروسيه على الاراضي
الاوكرانيه ليعيده بذلك ما تحدث عنه قبل
ايام خلال زيارته لمدينه خرسون
[موسيقى]
نحن
السلام سيكون لبلدنا بكل اراضيه نحترم
القانون الدولي وسياده جميع الدول لكننا
هنا نتحدث عن بلدنا لهذا السبب نقاتل ضد
العدوان الروسي
اوكرانيا اكدت ان روسيا لم تتواصل رسميا
معها بشان احتمال عقدي محادثات السلامه
وطلبت بسحب القوات الروسيه بالكامل قبل
حصول اي مفاوضات قال مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني اوندريماك ان اي محادثات غير
مبنيه على سياده اوكرانيا ووحده اراضيها
ضمن حدودها المعترف بها دوليا لن تكون
مقبولا بدوره اعتبر
ميخايلوك مستشار مدير مكتب الرئيس
الاوكراني ان زمامه المبادره عسكريه بيد
اوكرانيا وان التفاوض في الظروف الراهنه
يعني بشكل او باخر استسلاما غير مبرر
[موسيقى]
لطاوله المفاوضات وستقدم لنا شيئا لكنها
لن تقترح السلامه وتحرير اراضينا ببساطه
تتوقف وخلال هذا الوقت ستحسد قواتها
وستبحث عن اسلحه اضافيه كما انها ستبني
التح على طول نهر النيبر
فرصه محتمله لبدء محادثات من اجل ايجاد حل
سياسي للنزاع ايضا المتحدث باسمي مجلس
الامن القومي جونكر بيعتبر ان المفاوضات
افضل الحلول الممكنه الا ان الامر يبقى
متروكا للرئيس الاوكراني بولودي ميرسلنسكي
ليحدد وقت وشكل هذه المفاوضات دون اي ضغط
على اكياف في هذا الشان